son commerce elle elle le tient depuis
l'après guerre c'est une grande surface
de faïence de gien au bord de la
nationale 7 dans le nord de la nièvre et
marguerite est une patronne hors normes
puisqu'elle est née en 1906 bien que
centenaire elle n'envisage pas de
raccrocher voici son portrait gerald
tessier régis clients alors là bas on
fête ses 101 ans
enfin un an aujourd'hui non 500 ans et 5
mois
les clients de passage n'en reviennent
pas cela fait 60 ans que marguerite n'a
pas quitté le comptoir de son entreprise
un immense magasin de poterie et
faïences qu'elle ouvre 7 jours sur 7
pour refuser la retraite marguerite
prétexte des stocks importants qu'elle
doit écouler avant de partir mais en
réalité
marguerite est une passionnée qui
n'arrive toujours pas à imaginer de ne
plus travailler ça me plaît moins
d'impôts aujourd'hui demain il faut
remplir le magasin nabab sortir qu'on a
on stoppe qu'on a vendu samedi manche
samedi et dimanche parce qu'on a quand
même fait une 2 millions il faut re
brochettes et au delà pour le faire
venir pour moi de gagner ma vie et pour
gagner sa vie marguerite ne laisse rien
au hasard elle scrute les allées de son
magasin accompagné d'armançon employé de
59 ans lui bientôt à la retraite
présentation étiquetage la vieille dame
est aussi impitoyable que ces prix sont
dites à l'imbattable une patronne très
fier et un armand qui ont fait les frais
il n'ya pas les 50% la ccc 50 % celle là
il faut des parcs comme sarments oui oui
dans les bienfaits de lire et dieu
marguerite compte bien le voir le plus
tard possible
elle qui a déjà enterré trois maris
laisse entendre qu'elle pourrait vendre
son affaire à la fin de l'année une
promesse qu'elle envisageait déjà dans
sa jeunesse
selon armand quand elle avait 80 ans
[Musique]